hey son I hope I owe that come to you
[Music]
man
welcome to you laughs you lose it's a
show where if you laugh you lose and the
rule is simple you show where you will
go there's a net sound great thanks
begin the tongue hey what's up
how's that part of the other night it
was all right what there's this guy he's
with his girlfriend are you trying to go
do something that she didn't want to do
so what'd you do about I didn't do
anything
well what guys don't but my friend here
who didn't doing and not doing is part
of the problem
[Music]
did that guy just freeze his friend in
time that's incredible
why'd you do that what guys don't but my
friend here who didn't do anything
trying to go do something that she'd
want to do so what'd you do about do
anything whoa yeah what's the only right
thing to do and next time please I urge
you listeners Hey
Oh keep down the food sighs you know
it's illegal
download copyrighted music I'm taking
you win hey free music never legally
download guys otherwise the mic is just
too good you know it's illegal
downloading copyrighted music I'm taking
you win
hey free music never legally download
guys please remember this important
message never illegally download if you
find yourself illegally downloading the
man can come in through the wall any
minute with a stapler in his hand and
yell at you you got a shitty ponytail
look that's not how you get a guy you're
like you're like 36 what are you doing
with the ponytail
yeah note two ladies don't wear your
hair in a ponytail wear it down on your
shoulders because then it indicates that
you are a female you got a shitty
ponytail yeah that's not how you get a
guy you're like you're like 36 what are
you doing with a pen test yeah note two
ladies don't wear your hair in a
ponytail wear it down on your shoulders
because then it indicates that you are a
female they must didn't know she was
there okay and my second question would
be to oh my god I saw this one I would
just like to ask how many of you have
autism and if so has it helped you in
your modding career we're going to
refuse that question I think yeah I'm
afraid we have to pass on that one sorry
all right
I would just like to ask how many of you
have autism and if so has it helped you
in your modding career could you just
said no I don't have autism or yes I
have autism and no you little [ __ ] it
has nothing to do with my modding career
what are you stupid
why are you filming with a camcorder
question on this left side of you I was
wondering um what's the waka man
of detonated wham eyes it have does
[Laughter]
dedicated a wham to a server commanded
amount of detonated wham eyes do you
want anyone can be a gamer even if it's
like doing a Sudoku on your phone no I
mean to some pretty hardcore stuff this
says I'm a pretty hardcore gamer right
now anyone can be a gamer even if it's
like doing a Sudoku on your phone damn
it
stop stop saying when will you learn
when will just call me a gamer I play
Satoko damn it I play Sudoku on my phone
how dare you say never game
[Music]
what's up Zack I mean come on there's
nothing funny about wrecking public
property okay take it from this guy nice
guy pretty pie but if Zack is there oh
my god that's hilarious this restroom
right and then I don't know where just
sack comes out absolute man lad you
shouldn't have had that audio in the
back I guess it was quiet but that
that's pretty good
and an airplane
we the things he owns the armrest
I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna try to
get some video of me showing that if he
wants to cuss it with the hustle he's
gonna get it
hopefully I get it on camera
Oh
you got chain boy you got child
this is what happens when you do cross
fitting guys you you become an absolute
alpha that cannot be wrecked with by
anyone
look at this man he completely destroyed
these masculinity is might as well left
it on the ground from where he started
along with his testicles this man is
done this man is finished and he knows
it and he's just taken a last glimpse of
what he could have been
[Music]
right oh really
right what an absolute alpha did you
laugh or did you lose let me know in the
comments make sure to subscribe buy a
t-shirt
buy all everything you can donate to my
patreon please I need money check out
another episode of you last Mueller and
I'll see you guys in the next episode
make sure to subscribe
[Music]
[ __ ]